because obviously you know you explained
what you wanted to be in the same sex
couple
essentially because you didn't want to
wear the dresses and everything but
equally you must be aware of
what it's like for kind of a young girl
or young boy
who you know feels different to see
themselves on telly
yeah definitely i mean it's it's really
good to have that kind of diversity on
tv
um and i didn't think i didn't think
it'd be such a big deal
you know but i guess it is for some
people but i i think
i guess you just have to always push the
boundaries and just show people you know
it's just
it is just two women dancing it's not
you know
a big deal it's like most of these
things i think
that it's a big deal till it happens
yeah and then everyone's just like oh
yeah oh yeah
yeah the thing is you've retired haven't
you retired from boxing yeah
you're still so young is there any
little bit in your head where you're
thinking
maybe i'll go back i'll i'll you know
because a lot of boxers are tempted back
into
yeah yeah it's like but no no
yeah i've i've i've had enough like i've
i've literally have
um i've won everything so yeah
my work here is done
you